what's going on at the hour fam just
wanted to take a minute to say thank you
to all of you who've been engaged who've
been riding with me on this podcast so
to speak over the last year and for
those of you who've jumped in even after
the year began just want to take a
minute to thank you all since we are
actually at our one year anniversary of
launching the podcast with our fresh
first episode drop in march of 2021 it's
been a great journey to be on with all
of you this is not the end by any sense
we have lots of new episodes coming up i
did want to take a moment just to
acknowledge all the support and
engagement and encouragement um that all
of you listeners have
given over this past year also for
today's episode we're doing something a
little bit different the conversation is
actually going to be centered on a new
play a new production that's ongoing at
the ensemble studio theater in new york
city called what you are now and it
really is a culmination and a
representation of neuroscience meets the
arts um and this this actual play has so
many topics that are at the heart of
what we talk about on this podcast so in
this conversation today i'm honored to
be able to host the playwright sam
chance as well as three cast members
from the production for say powell
robert lee lange and sonny brown it's a
great conversation and with that let's
just go ahead and jump in
well welcome back to another episode of
the addie hour it's great to be here
with all of you and as always i've
really enjoyed hosting these
conversations and just having the
opportunity to peel back the layers as
it were on so many important topics and
to have so many different guests from
different walks of life who've been able
to share their professional expertise
and their personal experiences as well
it's been encouraging to hear how you
all as audience members and listeners
have really engaged in these topics and
today i'm excited to be able to carry
that conversation forward again i had
the opportunity to actually see a
preview of this play a few weeks back
and it's really powerful and gripping
story about memories about trauma about
resilience and hope centers on the
family and the story of a family of
cambodian refugees here in the united
states and their journey also leans into
the lead character who's actually a
neuroscientist researching memory
formation and also thinking about ways
that memory can be altered and perhaps
even removed when thinking about the
traumas and challenges her family has
been through
so today again i'm honored to be able to
be able to host the playwright and some
of the cast members for what i think
will be a really great conversation
we're doing something a little bit
different because we have four guests
for the first time
i usually have three or less but i think
this conversation is one that's really
going to flow well and also knowing the
work that they've done together as a
group i'm really excited to be able to
host a conversation
so to start out i'd like to introduce
sam chance who is the author of the play
she is someone who has been deeply
involved in lots of different types of
work i promised her i'd keep the
introduction short not to go on too long
about the accolades so i'll leave it
there for now but we'll also come back
at some of her investment in this topic
as we go through but first thing i want
to actually pass it on to sam to
introduce the cast members who are here
joining us today so sam i'll pass it
over to you
sure uh so i'm just going in order of
the zoom boxes as they appear on my
screen
to say pal is uh here with us
you're all in new york i happen i'm in
california right now but uh fsa it's
playing the role of pia in the play uh
robert li lang who is
uh
playing who plays the role of durrani in
the play and
sani brown who is playing the role
of shantriya um and sam i actually
wanted to start out with you you know as
my listeners know
i often just like to check in and see
how people are doing at this moment in
time um and with everything that we've
you know walked through in the last few
years i know for the ensemble studio
theater this was the first production in
a while that was actually done in person
with a live audience um so i just wanted
to ask you know what that experience has
been like you know being back
with the production that you've written
uh on in an in-person setting how has
that been over these last few weeks
since the play has kicked off
no i i mean it's been really for me it's
been really uh
amazing to be in the
to have had the time in the room
with with folks i
and i wasn't there for the whole process
because
i'm in california right now so i haven't
been able so i was joining on zoom for a
while
which was familiar territory after the
last few years
and i think it always felt like this
production was very uncertain i think
everything has felt really
[Music]
um fragile and i kind of didn't know i
never really knew if things were going
to proceed from week to week like what
was going to happen and would this ever
have an audience would we ever be in the
space together and
so
being in the space with
um with with everyone and working
together on this has been
just
it's just really
beautiful i can't and i think it really
is uncertain also and i feel aware of
that like it feels like everyone's been
really putting a lot out there to be
there and risking a lot and um
after the last few years i think it just
yeah i don't i i think there's a
different kind of
awareness of the preciousness of being
together in space yeah
yeah that's really well said um and
mirrors just a lot of things you know
just i'm sure as you all have or just
from so many folks too that held those
two together i mean having that precious
beautiful moment but also the
uncertainty that's there at the same
time um so definitely appreciate how
honestly you shared that still true um
in a lot of ways um the other thing i
wanted to ask just to get a feel from
the cast members as well how has that
been for you all being back on stage and
having having people in the audience
actually uh listening in and
engaging with you and then also if you
could actually just talk about maybe a
little bit about your journey and what
drew you um to this production as well i
realized i just asked three questions in
one but i'm going to let you all take it
from there actually if we could start
with paseo i'd be great sure um
i think i'm just sort of still uh
um
what's the word um
what sam just said really really touched
me about the uncertainty
it i think that she just hit something
that's sort of been inside me for the
last
couple of months of working on this play
the uncertainty of whether this play was
going to go
on you know we test every week so at any
point in the week we could be shut down
whether we're going to have an audience
um this is my first time
on stage so the uncertainty there so the
weight of that is just sort of
hitting me
at this very moment wow and it's really
really
i think
closely tied
to being a refugee
um the uncertainty that my parents felt
and the uncertainty that i felt growing
up in general
um
and it's just all hitting me right now
at this very moment because of that one
word that
sam said so thank you sam for
for um
for sharing that um
i think that definitely encapsulates
my process
you know moving forward but not certain
if
if we are going to actually go forward
but still continuing
just like
marching marching on
um
because
you know
damn if i'm gonna get on stage and not
know my lines
so
i don't know if that answers all of your
questions but that's definitely
where i am at this very moment just
having heard um what sam had to share
yeah thanks so much for sharing that and
just being in the moment too i mean it
sounds like a lot of it's just kind of
hitting you in a way all at once that
happened before would you say that did
you kind of sense it as you were walking
through
um or was it also because i mean at some
level i
assume you're also trying to be about
your craft about your work so you think
it's something that
you just were focused in the moment and
this at this time have time to pause or
do you think you kind of sense that as
you're moving through that kind of
feeling of uncertainty
i think i definitely sensed it but um
i'm you know reading this book right now
called the body keeps the score
and you know one of the main things
about
trauma is that you don't have
that most people can't verbalize it they
can't put a word to what they're
experiencing
so i've definitely sensed it throughout
this whole process
but
i didn't realize that what that what i
was sensing was uncertainty
um even though i was feeling it sort of
you know all throughout
because of all the different factors
that we were talking about with kovid um
especially and with it being my first
experience so yes
um a thousand percent
i sensed it yeah yeah and when
sam put a word to it it just sort of
like
binged yeah
yeah that's really well said appreciate
you staring uh so honestly as well
sanji what about you how's this process
been for you
it's been an amazing process
i remember
one of the early rehearsals asking our
director steve carson um is there a
possibility the show's not going to go
on you know because
we'd had
the last surge of covet
and it was affecting a lot of people and
i was like wow okay so what's going i
mean are we here rehearsing for
ourselves
um
but
even if we were just rehearsing for
ourselves the play hit me in such a way
that it was worth it
because um
i told sam this a couple of times and i
tell everybody this is the best role
i've ever had wow just uh
in the complexity of the woman
the things that she's gone through um
that
people can find humor in her
and
that she can break some hearts is
is a dream role
i mean it's amazing for me um so the
whole process has been incredibly
uh fulfilling
but at the same time in the background
there's all this stuff going on in the
world
and
covet is still a thing
and we're still getting tested we had a
couple of scares um
but
we
i mean i personally can only speak for
myself um it's all been worth any kind
of
stress or
um uncertainty from my for me personally
it's just been
a great journey wow that's really
powerful that's so great to hear i mean
in a sense as you're both sharing
everything you're continuing to navigate
even as you're you know about your work
and putting this on for audiences as
well so definitely appreciate that uh
full spectrum of emotions and feelings
that have kind of been going on all the
same time
robert what about you
how's the process been
um
the process has been
uh
it's been a lot it's been um
i think to
you know to kind of be present in this
moment and and
you know and hear what
um sam persay and sunny are saying it's
it's definitely
highlighting
um
some of the
the emotions and some of the
the struggles that have that have stuck
out the most for sure and you know and
living within this
you know collective time of uncertainty
um
definitely has been a lot of that and i
think a lot of the days
i've
tried to
be
as fully present and committed and kind
of
you know
try to put aside some of that
you know um
wanting things to be
headed somewhere
you know um
and there's been a weird relationship
with time i think my concept of time has
always been
very strange like
you know early on in rehearsals
i would have this feeling every day of
like
you know we come here every day and
every day is new but then we're doing
the same things
but and it's like
this is how we choose to live our lives
like we come every day we commit and we
put so much hard work
into doing this for so many hours every
day and i'm like this is this is really
beautiful but it's also such a
i think it could be kind of overlooked
of like
you know you do this every day like you
commit your time
on this planet to doing this every day
and i'm like yeah like this is this is
what we do and then with all of the
uncertainty it just adds kind of like a
weight to it an extra layer of weight to
it
um
but
overall it has been amazing in so many
ways that that i think are
you know so many things have been
challenging
challenging and painful and
you know um
like
a pulling open of
you know
of yourself
but overall um
has been amazing and i think it's such a
yeah grateful to have this experience so
far still going yeah still going still
going yeah
well i appreciate that level of candor
too as you all have been sharing just
the process you've all been going
through because again that's not
something i think people would
necessarily
see
at the front end walking into the play
um but at the same time you know as you
all have been sharing you know some
thoughts are coming to mind as well one
because again there were so many aspects
of the play that you all pulled in
together i mean aspects of memory
aspects of trauma racism race relations
assimilation you know refugee status
family dynamics um and obviously i'm
biased and watching it play too because
i felt like all the topics in the play
were all the things that we're about on
this podcast um as well so it was really
nice to see that brought to life in a
sense but then even watching the preview
and this may have just been me too but i
felt like you know a lot of the emotions
that were in the play really kind of um
leapt off the stage in a sense and felt
very real to me in that moment and so
i'm also just curious as you all because
you've touched on this already just your
own life experiences you know how this
has been one of the most powerful
roles that you've been in how has your
own
life experience within this moment and
just in general
impacted how you've walked into the art
in a sense um and i'd actually just be
curious to see you know those emotions
that i seem to sense that seem so
genuine to me was that
completely you all being just that
excellent in your craft or other aspects
of yourselves that also came
into that as well so again i'm asking
lots of questions at once but
i'm just curious if you all would want
to comment on any of those those
comments or
aspects i might start with you to kind
of reverse the order this time around
not to put you on the spot but
okay um
just like how our life has been our
journey leading up to this point like
how it's kind of like like blending it
together
just proceed for myself yeah um
ah damn um
i think it had to have happened like
this
you know at times
you know i do kind of think about
you know fate in a way
and
some things are too much to be just
coincidences and
i think
there's so many things i don't
understand but
sometimes uh
sometimes
things just kind of
make sense in some weird existential way
and i think that in in terms of my life
i feel like there's so many
stages in my life where i just got
completely lucky
just you know without really being able
to understand it
um just feeling like i just got lucky
somehow
and
you know starting this process being
here and having these conversations with
all these great people
i'm like oh
it seems like all that luck kind of like
contributes to
a purpose
you know um where i'm like oh well then
it kind of like makes you look at things
and fast a little differently of like oh
um
you know those a lot of those things
needed to happen for for this to be
possible i think
for me to allow myself to do this to see
things in this way
um to try to work in this way uh
to be giving and accepting
you know a lot of these processes which
are
difficult
um
and
i think i think something
quickly is that like i think i lived a
certain way where
um
somehow i continue to stay really
curious about things and and right now
like even in this moment throughout this
breath this rehearsal play process
is like
i feel like i
i feel like i i
like as as a man walking through the
world
slowly get into a place of like
of getting
like putting a lot of those things down
you know
um which is really which is hard but i
feel like the more i put down
in terms of
in terms of what it means to be a man or
what i've
conceptualized in my mind from a kid up
until now is that like the more i let go
the more i put down the more i kind of
like
um break down and and let kind of
dissolve like the more
i feel like i can really be of service
and really be a part of something
and um
i think i'm being vague
but uh
you know but being around
all this all the great women that that
i've had to a chance to talk to and kind
of trust and just you know just open up
to has been
a gift and very like
in a very kind of like personal
way
um and i think living my life has been
it's almost it feels almost 180 you know
like wow you know i grew up at a time
you know where
in my neighborhood the people i grew up
with the ideology of people around me
was just so toxic you know
um
and then just even
living growing up in a cambodian
american family
you know it's like there's so much
silence and there's so much
uh
pain and violence and just chaos like
all the time and it's like
you know i feel lucky that i was able to
kind of like
maintain myself somehow
this process is a continuation of that i
feel like
if that makes sense yeah definitely
yeah definitely thank you
oh of course thanks for sharing too i
mean just
that level of openness as well and it
may feel vague but also not big in a lot
of ways too i think just understanding
what what you're getting at and just you
know the great um women you've been able
to be around it sounds like in this
production as well just the learning
process has been so thanks for sharing
that definitely appreciate it
sony about what about you in terms of i
mean you mentioned this was
one of the roles that you the role that
you've enjoyed the most
and how much of that has just been from
the character itself and how much of
that is from others like what about this
role really brought you to that place to
say that um well she goes on a journey
like a very
profound serious journey of character um
from a place of denial kind of
of
you know of wanting to not share
the trauma in her life to protect your
children from that knowledge i feel like
that's at least that's how i'm playing
her
uh
because i feel like you know you
experience horrific things everyone does
and there are levels of trauma that
people go through you know that
can seem
nothing to stop one person but to that
person it is just as real you know and i
and me wanting to protect her you know
the kids from that from knowing you know
the horrors that i've seen because i
want them to live a normal life that is
without that
um
but then it kind of starts to come home
for the character we're in a very real
way like she's losing her grip on
her family you know and they're going
away and and
not wanting to spend time with her and i
feel like in a desperate desperate act
she's like okay i will try this to give
you what you are asking of me
um but it ends up framing her too in a
way where she can release
the toxicity inside of her and be able
to
do things that she thought were dead to
her all these years you know um i feel
like that's a very real journey that a
lot of people go through um personally
how i
bring that to life
um
you know we all
all actors have their little secret bags
um and uh you know uh you don't
talk too much about them because they
are your secret things um and not
everyone needs to know
where you mine some of that gold from
um
i
but in a very real way on stage i try to
make it is um
like i have two children on stage and i
love them deeply and i would die for
them if i had to you know i mean and
that that's that's a very real feeling
especially if you have a child you
understand that in your soul
you know if something were to happen
you would
easily
gratefully die for those children
it's just something that's universal
um
and so i can bring that much of myself
to as a mother
you know to that role and then the rest
of the trauma
it's not that difficult these days to be
able to draw on the horrors of the
war you know uh and use some of that
but i usually
as
things that i draw on to prepare to go
to a dark place for two hours every day
for six days a week
or sometimes four hours depending on
which day it is
um
you have to go into a very dark place in
your head you know i and um i've been
able to do it
fairly quickly where i don't have to
live there all day long
because that can be a very difficult
person to live with for my family
you know um
so yeah i
it's
honing the craft knowing how to access
the good and the bad in yourself to try
to bring it so people can relate to it
in a very meaningful way you know
so but uh the core of it uh for me
all of this performance is all about
love
yeah and that comes through so strongly
as well so i think you were definitely
effective in that and just the way you
were able to
bring all those parts of yourself into
the character and because that love
definitely came across as well just the
journey that you're on
because as that's the mother as well
thanks so much for sharing
but say to uh to come back to you as
well because again that you know my
comments about the emotion like i felt
it throughout and with all of the
members of the cast but especially with
your character in particular like a lot
of that just felt so
so honest and real authentic and raw all
the same time so just curious how you're
able to to you know hone the craft even
as sunny was talking about so
so effectively in that space and how
much of that again was from
a personal place or even just you know
just being that much in the craft or any
of those
those pieces in between
thank you um for that i appreciate you
saying that
um you know when you first asked the
question my stomach immediately started
to churn and i was like oh my god thank
god he's starting with robert
and then i was like oh
oh okay what is that you know what does
that mean
um
when i first auditioned for it there's a
scene
and i was um
sort of practicing with my partner
and
he and we do a lot of that you know
especially nowadays when everything is
sort of done over zoom
and um
and he turned off the camera and he was
really concerned for me
really concerned about
the words that i was saying and how
you know it felt so connected to what my
life has been and what he knows of me
and so my challenge has been because pia
is a different human being for me as
much as i connect with her on a lot of
different levels
my challenge was sort of really trying
to find that separation
um
and
and make sure that i honor her as a
character
but of course there were things that
that that came in that you know couldn't
be helped and then when those moments
come
[Music]
you know
the thing with live theaters you gotta
go you gotta go with it which we've been
doing with like you know the cell phones
going off and uh the pipes going off
um
and i think i find
for me i find character through
other people through real people and or
through
movies that i watched and in this case i
was sharing with sam
um i have a relative who reminds me so
much of pia
you know she
was talking about growing up and having
to run to her neighbor's house
because
her parents were so scary
but when she talks about it
it's just sort of like as if she's
sharing you know her favorite ice cream
shop from when she was a kid it's not
like it was super traumatic for her and
oh my god like save me it was just more
like oh yeah this is what happened
um so i drew a lot from that experience
i have a friend who
um
is an audiologist totally different from
being a neuroscience but a
neuroscientist but um you know went
through all the schooling and at one
point at one intersection in her life
she did have to make a sacrifice and not
go
to a particular school
in order to
help her family
um and so i've been lucky enough to
draw from the community
um
that
that i have
which
and i was telling robert this too when
we first met i was like i am not that
kind of cambodian because
i didn't grow up in a place like little
massachusetts i didn't grow up in long
beach california where there really is a
very
um there's a bigger cambodian community
and everyone's sort of you know
interacting and speaking with one
another and hanging out
i
i grew up in a very um mostly white
neighborhood
so in some ways i was sort of ostracized
from
my own community um but
you know
no one like
obviously no matter where i go if i meet
another my person so welcoming you know
because
our community has been so separated um
so i feel really blessed to be able to
talk to my cousin who i haven't spoken
to in years or to talk to my girlfriend
also haven't spoken to in years to feel
that community and that connection
um
and then also
the the words on the page
are everything
you know i don't have to
do a ton of work because everything that
pia is saying and everything the other
character's saying
um
it's just like how can you not feel
you know when something's true when
something's honest it's very very hard
to turn away from it
and that also applies to robert and
sonny
[Music]
who you know came with such honesty it's
how do you turn away from
your scene partner
when they're giving you so much
to
to play on i was really worried about
the very ending like if i could get
emotional every night and i'm like thank
god for sonny
because just looking at her
is and seeing what she's going through
and telling her story and then listening
to those words a combination of those
things
how can you not
be so
moved by what this woman is has gone
through
and the bravery
of having lived through that and raising
two children and then sharing it with
with her daughter so
it's a combination of of things
yeah really well said that authenticity
definitely came out throughout the
production too just i mean even as i'm
listening to you all talk about and
thinking back to the production and you
know having glimpses and
flashbacks isn't the best word to use
but you know thinking about how you all
looked at each other in certain moments
everything you just said really i mean i
can think back and see that and sense
that i think that's part of what was
giving me that feeling as well um as you
all entered into those spaces in a lot
of ways um so really appreciate again
the way that you all
have gone there in a brave way as well
because even as donnie mentioned that's
not a place that you can stay all day
long
forever for any for any number of
reasons but just the way that you all
are able to
weave in and now that and as you are
talking i get a sense of community
amongst the cast members and amongst the
production crew and everybody as well
which i think also
builds into what you all are doing so
again just really grateful for the way
that you all have captured that and
they're sharing that with audiences
sam i did want to loot back to you as
well again you know as a person who has
written this i'm going to mention a
quote that i saw on your website because
i really loved it the way that you
talked about your work exploring
interactions and collisions of race
gender
science and technology
and centering characters occupying some
kind of marginal space
you also mentioned that you hope to
contribute to efforts to eliminate and
elevate marginalized voices
i think that's just so powerful
um it's definitely the case for me when
i again when i watch the production and
have seen that in your work
um but also just wanted to talk a little
bit about you know because this
authenticity has really come out in this
conversation something i sense as well
how have you been able to really craft
that sense of authenticity in your work
even as you are elevating some of these
marginalized voices
well thanks for
for point for pointing to that
description i i
just want to say that i write i write
that as a way to understand what i do as
an impulse i think that a lot of us do
that i feel like a lot of us who are
who are who are members who are in
communities that are marginalized and
decent not centered
naturally have the impulse i mean it's
just
speaking from our own truth and
telling the stories that we know which
have not been centered and haven't been
um
and aren't widely recognized so i just
guess i just wanted to say too that
when i write that and
i it's trying to to just describe what i
think a lot of us do naturally um as
artists who who are making theater like
all of us on this call um
so i i feel it's just part of what
the
what the stories that i'm drawn to in
the stories that that are in me that and
or that i that i'm try that i want to
give voice to or that i naturally people
those are the ones that just
that emerge because they're part of the
the the people who have been part of my
lives and
my life and the people who i interact
with and
the the stories i identify with
um and in terms of how
i wouldn't i don't know how
i just know that whenever i'm writing
something and this is true for this play
it's always about how am i connecting
like i'm always connecting with the
uh
the characters and the journey that
they're on and it i i
i have to
i wouldn't write it if i wasn't
identifying strongly with them um and i
don't know how that will
if that will you know resonate or not it
but it always there's a kind of
gravity to the
i i feel that i'm drawn to
certain
um
material and characters and stories and
then
maybe that's
when i'm writing i'm i'm
writing from that perspective and with
with with this play i feel like i really
connected with the
mother like with the parent and child
and the silences that are in the family
i think that that's something that a lot
of us have grown up with and i'm not
cambodian american
my dad's chinese my mom is a
pennsylvania dutch
so i
and i and i still
but there was something about the
quality of the
the silences and the inability to
connect and the longing to connect and
all of the different kinds of secrets
and traumas that are buried in families
and i think especially in
well not especially but i know in a lot
of immigrant families and
i
i just immediately
felt this
the longing to understand your history
your own history differently and feel
that maybe there are other possibilities
for the for what has already been
written for you or something that has
already been imposed on you
but that if you could
have some
ability to to connect differently with
members of your family and understand um
understand your yourself in a different
way and somehow
have
i think it's in this i think there's a
longing to do that for but i had the
longing to do that with family to be
able to
transform relationships somehow
understandable but i mean that was so
well said in a lot of ways too because i
think again what you just brought out
in the characters just that
i don't have to call it
discomfort
but just yeah that uncomfortable silence
and i felt like you know you all as
customers were just
excellent and pulling out what sam had
written into that too because i find
myself following you all in that moment
and reacting with you and say oh i wish
this could come out here i wish to come
so it just again felt so authentic and
real i think in a lot of ways that
people will connect with that um as well
and then i mean to be completely honest
also watching it as a neuroscientist and
that can be good and bad because i'm
thinking about what's happening in the
brain at this moment oh i wish this
learned behavior could change here and
this so i mean in a sense you all pulled
me along for the ride in an authentic
way that was having me
walk with you but also yearning for
things to be different thinking about
what's happening in the brain so
on lots of different levels again i
think it was really just important to
have those those stories told in such
authentic and powerful ways um but on
that level of authenticity as well and
again this is gonna be you know this is
something that's not maybe as
generalizable but again just watches and
neurosciences i think a lot of
scientists from different fields who
might watch the play will also be
encouraged to see how well
you all integrated some of those
scientific concepts again in a
thoughtful and authentic way that had
real life application because there's
always that tension as well
when sam and i were talking one of the
things we talked about as well was just
this tension that sometimes comes up
within scientific communities of
promising new therapies and new changes
but then having that balance of how
realistic is this is it something that
we can see in one to two years this is
something five ten twenty years down the
road and so again from a point of
authenticity it was really nice for me
to see that interplay and that tension
also play out
in the production as you all were
talking about memories um and traumas
and whether those things could be
rewritten and
removed even but then also this tension
of well is this something that we can
only do in rats and mice or this
actually have applicability to humans as
well so without going into the weeds as
a neuroscientist because that that's a
tendency that i could definitely
lean towards but i didn't want to
mention that that level of authenticity
just in terms of bringing that part to
life was something that really struck me
um as well um and then again as a mental
health advocate just again getting back
to those those awkward or uncomfortable
silences the ways that you've all
highlighted that and that was probably
that verse that i was having to kind of
push things forward as well just because
you know we've talked about that in a
lot of different communities um even in
um
you know in african-american black
communities and others immigrant
communities as you all have mentioned
i'm also the son of immigrants but the
ways that those things can be attention
and sit um so i'm wondering if any of
you would be willing to just share you
know what you've observed either within
cambodian cambodian american communities
in terms of you know these awkward
sciences are things moving forward
because in the play that was definitely
something i took away that you're trying
to move these things for and that didn't
happen in the play in terms of talking
about
some of the mental health challenges and
traumas but anything you all are willing
to share from either your experiences
your observations um in the communities
that you've been involved in in terms of
mental health conversations
first i want to say
i am not a member of the cambodian
american community i am of korean
heritage um but i was raised by uh the
browns
who are a very white couple from new
upstate new york um so i i cannot speak
to that question um i can say that as an
actress
um
therapy is not
a foreign
island at all because most actors are
troubled enough where they need to
a good amount of therapy
just to be able to access themselves and
know what's going on in their emotional
lives so
um
it has like i i understand the the
benefit
of being the go through your own
personal
ghosts and and uh
horrors and
and to bring it out as an actress that
helped and actually
i i don't think it would be
the idea of erasing people's memories i
feel like is um
would take away from that person like
like durrani says in the play you know
that you change that person you know you
don't want to erase everything
there because it could affect them in a
way where they may not be recognizable
you know and um and i i believe that you
know
even though
if it keeps you from being able to live
your life
at all
where you can't get out of bed and you
just want to die all the time then yeah
maybe it would have some sort of benefit
but for for most people i feel like
you you need your history
but um for the rest of the community i
can't speak to that at all that would
have been robert and to say
i appreciate you sharing that
perspective as well i agree with you
just uh and then we've talked about this
on the pocket science but the
learning that can happen from painful
and challenging situations that you
wouldn't want to lose and remove as well
even though they still are challenging
um i guess i'll say
the the the cambodian american
experience in
the community in in my mind in my heart
and also the mental illness
as his own thing are very kind of
interwoven
in in my experience
um
and
that just is i'm always
good or bad or or you know there's so
many conversations to have with that but
that's just has that's how it has been
for me
um
and uh
you know per se is reading this book
which i i really love like when i first
read that book i
it changed a lot of my ideas i saw
things very differently
um after that
and um
i think
man i don't know i have very strong
opinions i think in about when it comes
to the conversations that we have about
mental health and i think we're
definitely having more conversations
today
but it's one of those things that feels
like
we're trying to unearth more of like the
realities of how we have been having it
before there's been so much damage done
i feel like maybe i'm just so hyper
focused on certain on those things
but
you know i've witnessed
i witness people
who are close to me be
you know be heavily kind of like
corralled within that like big pharmacy
and
the uh the larger kind of like
confirmation bias of what health is and
we know that you know over time it's
been
revealed to be a lot of fallacies in
terms of health in general and mental
health
and uh
sometimes i just get like you know i'm
not sure if it's worth moving forward
even though i ultimately faith-wise i do
believe that we are moving forward right
with mental health and with the
cambodian american community in terms of
um
how those two things come together
faith-wise i do believe we are going
forward it just feels like it's one of
those like you know two two steps
forward one step back and sometimes just
one step forward two steps back and i'm
just like you know ultimately i do think
we are going forward
um
it's just really difficult you know it's
um
you know i think
again with these marginalized
communities and also
with compass with topics that are not
generally
widely at scale
had
um his challenges there you know so
because it's important to me that
doesn't always mean it's going to be a
point to everyone else and it's like
there's a struggle there with having
that conversation
but you know i'm grateful for this
conversation because that's what we're
talking about and that's what's needed
yeah
um
yeah yeah that's really all i said i'm
with you on that 100 too and
you know some just thinking as as you're
talking to and this may be related also
a little bit but just so you know like
you mentioned a lot of things moving
forward but also moving back and the way
that things are sometimes portrayed or
talked about um you know another thing
that we've talked about just on this
podcast culturally like how are people
actually talking about
mental health and when we go to
different communities are we centering
that on a white male experience are we
actually thinking about the culture that
people are coming from and that
definitely stood out in the play too as
you all were
acting out the different roles but like
what what understanding that people have
about other people's experience that
cultural competency so i don't know if
that's where you're heading but that's
one thing that came to mind as you're
sharing too which i think makes things
go back and forth sometimes too because
you can actually end up making things
worse because you're approaching in one
framework there's a real important topic
to discuss within mental health but you
approach it approach it from the wrong
angle that you actually do more
more harm so i think those are really
important
conversations and again for me it's
encouraging to feel you know robert is
meant to be able to have this
conversation in this space to continue
to elevate those
pieces and to make sure that things are
done in a way that's appropriate and
there's room for learning and that no
one says they have kind of all the
answers from one framework alone so as
you can tell that definitely
resonates with me as well
to say anything that you want to add
on that topic because
yeah a couple of things that came to
mind for me was like well i don't i
didn't want to
um answer that question because i was
like well i don't want people to think
that my
experience is the cambodian-american
experience
um
so
my parents really were open to talking
about it talked about her all the time
um
i just didn't listen when i was a kid
um or they talked about it in different
ways you know it was like you must be
cambodian at home you're not allowed to
speak english you know because
we had so much a race or you have to
learn how to do cambodian ballet or
listen to cambodian music so it felt
like was very forced upon
but then of course i hear
people whose parents never spoke about
it
um i was talking to another a mixed
cambodian-american friend who didn't
know who uh
i said kamai kaham which is um our
translation for the khmer rouge
and he didn't know who that was and i
was like blown away
that he at least had didn't know
what that word was because i heard it
all the time growing up
and then i remember hearing about
someone's relative who
was homeless because they had some
mental issues and it shocked me
it was like
i can't imagine anybody in the cambodian
community being homeless
because
you know we always take care of our own
was the idea so
that's just all to say
that there is just such a wide range
of experiences
and also based upon i'm certain
you know which wave you came in that was
something that was really new to me
when i started doing the play is
realizing oh
that's why some cambodians might be
different from me or others is depending
on the wave so were you the first wave
that got out
um with the american troops escaping
cambodia because you had the money or
even prior
were you the second wave which i can't
remember quite when that was maybe that
was
right when things were falling and then
or the third wave which is
what my family went through being
refugees
being in thailand after the country had
fallen so i'm certain that
your mental health
and experience is also based on that
um another thing that came up for me was
my family and i um
were blessed enough to go back to
cambodia together
i'd gone there with just my mom
and then a friend and then my brother
who was born in the camps with me and my
sister who was born in america
we all went together so there are these
like three very different experiences
um
but what really struck my brother
um
was how happy everyone was and he's a
very happy person
but he couldn't believe
you know
you're going to a third world country
um there's people who don't have nearly
as much materialism as you do
electricity running water and he was
like people here are so happy
it was what his experience was
and then
you know learning that there isn't a
word
for depression i mean i don't know the
word robert if you know the word for
depression and command i'm
happy to to hear it to be educated but
there isn't even a word for that
um so how do you begin to have a
conversation about
something that again going back to like
you know verbalizing the thing which
you're experiencing is so important how
do you begin to have that discussion
when you don't even have a word for the
thing that you're supposed to try to be
verbalizing
so
not an easy answer yeah there's a real
answer
um
yeah
yeah and i appreciate you highlighting
those complexities as well because it's
not a monolithic experience like you
mentioned just the different pieces that
you've even started to see more and more
over time which i know it's going to be
helpful for all of us to continue to
think about so i appreciate you
mentioning and just sharing your
experience going back as well with your
family and your brother just although i
mean there's so many things we could
actually unpack there as well but
definitely appreciate definitely
appreciate that yeah yeah of course
so if we start to wrap up the time has
gone quickly sam i want to loot back to
you and also just talk about i'm here
what you want audience members to
actually take from the production as
they're watching it and experience it
and then we'll ask the others as well
yeah that's always a hard question i
feel like everyone comes to it so
different with their own set of
experiences and
like different elements of the play will
resonate differently for
everyone and i and i don't mean that to
not answer the question i just think
that i don't have like what i want
people to take from it i
i just hope that it connect that people
connect with it in some way that it
illuminates something for them or
um
allows
that that people
can respond respond and like feel some
connection with the material
in a way that
you can take like reframe something or
it allows you to maybe experience
something
um a little bit differently or see
or see something a little bit
differently or or reinforce something i
mean i know
even if someone pushes back against
something very strongly and um i think
that's
engagement
and for me it's about connecting with
people
connecting with people and whatever way
people come to the story in whatever way
they connect with it is
how that person
will connect and i think
so
yeah that's how i feel
really well said
that was still that was a good answer to
that question not avoid it but i think
that's really really really important
we phrased that
robert what about you maybe i should
rephrase the question a bit so not
necessarily that people would take from
it but while you're also hoping to maybe
just the hope that you have for
us as a society moving forward
just either personally or within the
context of the production
yeah um
i think my hopes have been
very
focused
throughout this entire thing and still
is now is that it's very simple i i just
i'm only hoping that cambodian people
see it and
can have a growing sensation or growing
um
feeling of of their own
cells of their own importance
of their own place in the world
um and that has been kind of like my
only concern like i actually to be very
honest i'm not really concerned with
anyone else seeing it at all um
and it's just like
you know i get really
i get really
so many mixed emotions but i do get very
happy to think about someone having that
experience and because i know some of
the experiences i've had and the
struggles i've had to kind of like come
into myself and
to allow myself to be like you know this
is something i
i deserve or there's something that is
like i'm worth this or that you know and
if there's anyone out there who has
similar experiences to me who feels that
way
i relate to that and i think it can be
very important for that person to have
that experience to sit there and
essentially be talked about
for two hours you know and eventually
you start to get that feeling you know
is that like if i sit 100 people down
and i talk about you for two hours
eventually you're gonna be like oh maybe
i'm important because people are like
you know staying on it
yeah so that's my hope that's my hope
and and and uh i don't know how far i
can go i don't know all the different
ways that it can be received or all the
different responses but
that is that is my hope
yeah i appreciate that being seen
being seen and elevated in lots of
different ways thanks so much for
sharing that i can definitely tell that
passion is there too so
sonny what about you
what i hope people take away from well i
hope not just cambodian americans see
this or
i i hope everyone sees it um
because i feel like there are universal
truths being told
um in the show and i so i feel like it
can resonate with a lot of people i mean
i more than one mother has come up to me
and said i know that relationship
between mother and daughter
i was like
cool
hey then you can recognize that
something that that you know um that
we've brought to life
on stage um
i i i would like people to understand
the truth of the that's being told you
know that uh america is not
the big hero that everyone wants them to
believe we are we we're a great country
but we have flaws and we have done some
heinous things
um and i think shedding a light on that
so because a lot of people only know
vietnam a lot of people don't understand
full pot you know and what happened in
cambodia and that's something that
should be taught in history alongside
with a lot of other stuff
along the
a lot of people are trying to uh
whitewash
if that's the way we're right um
right now it's going on censoring is
going on and i feel like
it's important now to tell
the truths of
whether it puts you in a bad light or
not the truth is more important because
hopefully it will be repeated you know
historically
like it is being done down today
so yeah i feel like it's important in
that way that everyone should see it
yeah
really well said
say i'm going to give you the final word
um
uh
and i well just to say i should
definitely not have the final word um
you know after this is all said and done
and and people listen to the podcast
i i do hope that people it encourages
people to do their own research
and come to their own conclusions
um
about things that they may not have been
familiar with or things that interest
them
um
things that they may disagree with
whatever it may be um
i just know that you know when i get
really interested in something i'll
start googling it i'll start looking it
up so i think that's the important thing
is that we somehow peak someone's
interest out there
um my
my goal is twofold um one for
there's so much information in the play
so much good information information
that i didn't even know
so any any information that people can
take from the play
um
whether it's related to science whether
it's related to you know the brain and
relationships and fear memory or whether
it's related to
um you know cambodian stories that's
also really really rich there too sam
did such a great job of incorporating so
many experiences and ideas
um and and histories so anything that
people can take away from that aspect um
and say oh i didn't know that i had no
idea that makes me happy to hear my
friends
or whoever come to the play and say i
didn't realize that
um because that's the seed you know um
and then the second thing is you know
having
worked
on pia for so long
you know researching different aspects
of neuroscience and really thinking
about where she comes from and her
history and her story
you know i can't help but feel like a
kinship towards her
and really want to advocate and and be
protective of the fact that
you know i hope people can walk away
understanding
that you know
her blind spot was her love for her
family and her wanting
a need to
to have this connection
you know she's a lot of like very angry
outburst and a lot of um
she does a lot of things that maybe
didn't even make sense to me sometimes
so i think that
i hope
that parents
and children walk away
sort of understanding like oh is that
something that i do
or have experienced
myself and i did have one friend
who couldn't speak after the play she
was so emotional about her own
relationship with her kids
because she had seen the relationship
that
pia and sean trey had had so
you know in some ways it's like yes
we did it yeah um but yeah those are my
two goals yeah that's great
well again i appreciate what you all
have done in this production from the
writing to the acting to so many
different components and again just
how you all engaged in this conversation
too because i know you know some of
these topics are emotional too i know we
were entering in uh together so i
definitely appreciate your willingness
to do that and you can tell that this is
something i've been really excited about
so i also appreciate your patience with
my five questions in a row because
they're just kind of all bubbling out at
once
but again really grateful for the
production i hope folks this will be
airing in time for folks to still go and
see a production if they're able to so
i'm just um and again all things that
you all share just in terms of
the impact this can have for cambodians
and for society in general so grateful
for the time you all have taken to talk
here on the podcast i know the listeners
will
enjoy hearing this and i imagine that
people will do some research afterwards
and even go back and re-listen to the
episodes there's so many nuggets along
the way as well
so appreciate you all being here and
thanks so much for joining the addi hour
thank you doctor
thank you so much
[Music]
you